HAVE GUNS AND TAKE THEM INTO
PLACES OF WORSHIP.
I MEAN, IT IS ABSOLUTELY
IRRATIONAL.
>> Mark: JULIAN CASTRO,
MEANWHILE CLAIMS HEROIC ARMED
CIVILIANS ARE FICTIONAL.
AS FICTIONAL AS HIS PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
>> MORE GUNS ARE NOT THE ANSWER.
MORGAN'S DON'T MAKE US SAFER.
THIS IDEA THAT A GOOD GUY IS
GOING TO STOP A BAD GUY WITH A
GUN, IT DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY.
>> Mark: WELL IT SEEMED TO
WORK THAT WAY IN TEXAS
YESTERDAY.
RYAN, AN ATTORNEY AND FORMER
ARMY RANGER.
HE JOINS US NOW.
RYAN ON THE SNIPER SIDE OF YOU,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE MATCHING
FIREPOWER HERE, THE DISTANCE THE
HILL WOULD YOU WHAT MR. WILSON
DID IN THIS CHURCH YESTERDAY?
>> A+.
WHERE DO I START EXCEPT TO THANK
GOD FOR MR. WILSON AND HIS
HANDGUN, PRACTICING AT THE RANGE
FOR HIM TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THAT
ONE SHOT AND SAVE ALL OF THOSE
LIVES.
>> Mark: WELL, LET ME PUT IT
TO YOU THE JOE BIDEN POINT,
FELLAS LIKE HIM NEED ARMED
SECURITY DETAILS.
HE IS THE SECRET SERVICE DETAIL.
I BELIEVE HE SWIMS NAKED IN
FRONT OF MOST MORNINGS, WHICH IS
NOT SOMETHING I WOULD WANT TO
SEE PERSONALLY IF I WAS
SECRET SERVICE AGENT.
BUT THAT HE NEEDS ARMED SECURITY
AND EVERYBODY ELSE CAN DO
WITHOUT.
AND CAN JUST CALL 911.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHY WE HAVE A
SECOND AMENDMENT TO DEFEND
OURSELVES AGAINST THOSE WHO WISH
TO DO US HARM.
TO TALK ABOUT HOW GREAT THE
GOVERNOR ABBOTT FOR PASSING THIS
LAW, WHICH HE IS AND HE WAS, BUT
IT BOTHERS ME THAT WE HAVE TO
CELEBRATE THE FACT THAT HE
PASSED A LAW THAT GAVE THEM THE
RIGHT TO CARRY GUNS IN CHURCH,
NO, GUYS, OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS BELONG TO US BEFORE THE
GOVERNMENTS.
THE GOVERNMENT GIVES US THE
RIGHT TO CARRY IN CHURCH AND IT
IS SO SAD TO ME THAT WE HAVE TO
HAVE A LAW IN TEXAS THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO EXERCISE THE FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT TO DEFEND THEMSELVES IN
CHURCH.
IF WE LOOK AT THE ANTI-GUNNERS,
JOE BIDEN, HE IS WRONG.
HE WAS DEAD WRONG.
IF HE HAS HIS WAY, THERE WOULD
BE A LOT MORE PEOPLE DEAD IN
THAT CHURCH.
AND WE HAVE SOME ANTI-GUNNERS
LIKE SHARON WATTS WHO SAID THIS
ONLY HAPPENED BECAUSE IT WAS
ALLOWED TO HAPPEN BY
GOVERNOR ABBOTT WHO ALLOWS GUNS
IN CHURCH.
CRIMINALS AREN'T ALLOWED TO DO
ANYTHING WITH LAW.
AND WE TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE,
THE VERY DEFINITION OF A
CRIMINAL IS THEY DON'T OBEY
LAWS.
NO LAW ALLOWED THAT BAD GUY TO
WALK INTO A CHURCH AND KILL
PEOPLE.
IT IS SAD THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
LAWS ALLOWING TO DEFEND AGAINST
THAT.
>> Mark: THERE IS A LINE OF
HOMELAND SECURITY USED.
IF YOU SEE SOMETHING, SAY
SOMETHING.
BUT IN FACT, A LOT OF THE
POLITICAL LEADERS KEEP TELLING
US THERE IS ACTUALLY NOTHING TO
SEE HERE THAT WE ARE BEING
IRRATIONAL WHEN WE ARE SCARED OF
PEOPLE.
IN THIS CASE, A FELLOW WALKS
INTO A CHURCH, WEARING A WIG,
HE'S WEARING A FALSE BEARD, AND
SOMEBODY DID SEE SOMETHING AND
REACTED IMMEDIATELY.
IS THERE REALLY THE WAY WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE IN THE
FUTURE?
>> NO, NOT NECESSARILY, BUT I'M
GLAD THEY DID SOMETHING.
YOU SEE, I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
SEE SOMETHING, SAY SOMETHING.
I'M GLAD THESE GUYS DID
SOMETHING.
THE POLICE ARE 15 MINUTES AWAY,
SECONDS COUNT AND THEY ARE
HEROES AND I'M GLAD WE HAVE THEM
BUT WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR OUR
OWN SAFETY UNTIL THEY GET
THERE.
A STATISTICAL ARGUMENT MIGHT
SEEN THIS COME OUT OF THE
WOODWARD, AGAIN, THE BAD GUY WAS
STOPPED BY A GOOD GUY WITH A GUN
BUT HOW DO WE ATTACK NOW?
WE WILL ARGUE STATISTICS, YOU
PROBED ON PEOPLE CRAZY TO WORRY
ABOUT THIS.
YOU CAN HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
IT IS EITHER SO RARE AND IT WILL
NEVER HAPPEN, WE DON'T NEED GUNS
TO DEFEND OURSELVES, OR IT IS AN
EPIDEMIC AND WE NEED TO TAKE
GUNS AWAY.
ARGUING BOTH SIDES DOES NOT MAKE
SENSE.
>> Mark: AND THERE IS NO
POLICE DEPARTMENT ON THE PLANET